a good architect doesn't just know how
to design they also
know how to document
what's going on guys my name is david
tomic welcome back to the channel
today we're talking about construction
details in particular we're talking
about construction details starting from
the ground and working our way up
i'm going to be breaking down five
different construction details and how
you can detail them on archicad 24.
so we're going to be looking at a brick
to concrete slab construction we're
going to be looking at a timber to
concrete slab construction
we're also going to be looking at a
precast or a tilt up concrete wall
connecting to that concrete slab we're
going to be taking a look at the column
connection
into a concrete slab and finally last
but not least we're going to be looking
at a retaining wall
detail so these are very critical and
i'm going to make them very generic
so that anybody around the world can get
a fundamental understanding of
how it works in principle now obviously
building codes around australia differ
building codes around the world differ
building codes and standards everywhere
are very very different so i'm not going
to go into 100
specifics because i know that these are
going to change on your location however
it is going to give you a good
understanding
of one how to document it on arcade24
and two what is a reasonable
understanding of
that detail in particular now if you've
noticed this brand new fresh
jumper it has just arrived courtesy of
youtube basically once you hit 10 000
subscribers first of all
thank you guys so much for pushing me
across that line youtube
actually gives you your own merch store
now i didn't know that i had absolutely
no idea
i've grown this channel from zero now to
over 11 000 subscribers as i record this
video today
with nobody really around me doing
youtube i basically just
jumped on board and thought i would
share my skills my experience and my
passion with you guys
and it's led to something so far so
successful if you're interested in
grabbing some merch it is in the
description down below
there is an architect brand if you're an
architect and wish to portray
your career and your passion and there
is also a future
architect collection so if you're
somebody watching this aspiring to be an
architect
well make sure you grab one of those
future architect shirts that will help
you get there
and remind you every single day of your
goals anyway enough of me talking about
the merch and the store
and the great success so far all because
of you guys let's turn around to these
computers behind me and start
documenting some construction details in
arcade 24. so now that arcade 24 is open
up we're going to start by creating our
first construction detail
the construction detail we're talking
about in part one is
a concrete slab with a concrete footing
and
a double brick cavity wall get started
by coming over to our wall tool here on
the left hand side
we're going to keep the layer over here
as walls external overall not too
critical because we're more so doing
details but you know me i like my layers
being correct
let's come down all the way to the bw05
270 millimeter cavity brick wall
basically what that is is 110mm brick a
50mm
cavity and another 110mm brick so as we
do a construction detail it is a section
all the way through it isn't something
that we can only draw in 2d we like to
draw in 3d we like to work with it and
create it so let's start by clicking
once holding the shift button
clicking the d button and typing 1000
to draw a one meter long wall i'll then
click against
once more to finish off that double
brick wall
now with brick coursing obviously you
want to stick to brick coursing
a size brick is very typical so one
meter probably isn't achievable but
that's not what we're talking about
today
the next step is clicking control and
the down
arrow which is going to open up a new
story setting i'm going to call this
footings if i can type properly i'm
going to call it footings and i'm going
to go minus
100 millimeters in this case because
we're going to draw the slab as a 100mm
and we're going to draw our footings in
2d so let's click ok
moving underneath we'll scroll across to
our right panel over here
right clicking ground floor plan going
show as trace
and then what i'm simply going to do is
come across to the slab tool
and select a different type of slab now
let's go simply with a hundred mil
concrete slab with a tile finish
because this is brick we are gonna stop
the slab
right here on the internal leaf and then
we're gonna wrap it
back around just clicking and holding
shift to draw a perfect square
on the inside so what we'll do is
theoretically we'll call this the inside
of the house
and we'll call that the outside of the
house the next step is to grab
one of these section markers you can
steal one of the section markers already
on the page
or you can come down and actually draw a
brand new section
so we can click on this section tool as
an example click once
drag across and we want to look at the
section that way moving forward so now
what we can do is we can either find it
in our layout settings
or we can right click that section go
open with current view settings
so it's going to open up a brand new
view
and we're going to see we have multiple
areas straight away off the bat so
here is that concrete slab we drew
previously and here's our nice
brick wall basically what we want to do
is we want to click control
d and drag this all the way up to the
top
now if we measure this out we know we
have 10 mils of tiles
so once again we want to command d tap
the d button and
lift that up 10 millimeters now if you
see all these story setting lines i
absolutely hate them
so control 7 opens up our story settings
we can simply untick all of those boxes
get rid of it
and they will disappear from our view so
now we have this detail
which is still not anywhere close to
finished but it's a good starting point
basically what happens with a double
brick construction home
is the exterior leaf runs all the way
down to the footing itself whereas
the interior leaf stops on the slab now
this is predominantly from a
waterproofing issue and it's a very
common detail
so what we're going to do is actually
click once and extend that brick wall
just a little bit lower to the bottom of
this slab for now now i'm not personally
an engineer
engineers will always give you the exact
footing details the exact slab sizes
for that job because every single job is
different depending on the conditions
the wind
the soil there are so many factors that
we do not account for
so this again is just a very typical
understanding of what we're going
through what i'm going to do is just
start drawing this in 2d now to actually
be able to explain it so i'm going to
come over to my fill tool
go to my geometric pattern and select
the structural
concrete item here so i'm going to
change that to black and i'm going to
change that
to white so we have black
structural concrete hatches and a white
fill background
what i'm going to do here is simply go
down go 172
very traditional i'm going to go across
150
come across at a 45 degree angle
and just simply draw this out to the
underside
of the tiles so there we go
now we have our brand new concrete slab
which we can also see has a great
outline i don't want that i want a nice
black outline and then i'm just going to
again once again
extend that brick coursing all the way
to the bottom
of that slab thickening now i'm going to
hold the alt button over this fill click
once
click again holding shift and let's make
it a 450
by 300 footing so that is
our footing right here now what we could
also have is insulation
inside this cavity so if we come across
our object tool go to the object
type in insulation we'll get our fiber
insulation 24
now it's definitely not going to be 300
millimeters wide it's only going to be
50 millimeters
and we're also not going to have it on
the landscaping
let's just put it for general for now in
if we tap the control
e command it will give us the rotation
tool so we can rotate that 90 degrees
command d drop that in and basically
line that entire cavity with
insulation now there are only two more
real things that we have to consider
here
from a structural point of view there's
a lot more we can consider from an
architectural point of view
basically we need to understand where
the natural ground level is so if we
come back across to our fill tool
and find our earth hatch we can let's
change that back to a light gray
we can actually draw in our earth
underneath
all of this concrete and let's come up
maybe about 150 mil
above that concrete footing and we also
want to make sure that we're
returning our earth or sloping our earth
away from the building
so let's slope it just that little bit
so you can see the line
falling away from the building and i'm
also going to turn off the
outside perimeter line now the purposes
of falling the earth and the dirt away
from the brick
and the actual building itself is so
that any water ponding
next to the building will naturally fall
away
you don't want water falling in towards
the building because then you're just
going to have a lot of problems
so the earth should always be sloped to
at least a couple degrees away from the
building itself
now this black outline is definitely
incorrect so what i usually do
is turn off that outline select a gray
line let's go to a solid let's make it
green
just so it stands out clicking once and
there we go
there's our natural ground level we can
go ahead and annotate that we can go
natural ground level we can point to the
mass concrete footing
point to the external brick wall the
cavity field insulation
and all sorts of other details when we
detail it further but we're not going to
go into that much detail on screen
because like i said i like to articulate
this and explain everything
as we go through it but there we go
that's basically our
concrete detail from a structural point
of view of how a double brick
cavity wall sits on a concrete footing
with a concrete slab now we've finished
that detail we're going to close out of
that one
we're going to keep that there as it is
but we're going to move on to our timber
stud frame detail it is very very
similar to our brick coursing detail
but in somewhat of a different way so
basically let's copy this slab from down
below
let's copy that three meters up and
we'll move one floor up by pressing
control and up to get to our ground
floor i'm going to show
that as my trace reference just so i can
see what's going on
i'm going to select my wall tool again
come all the way down to 90 millimeter
stud
partition now just like we did with the
brick coursing we're going to click on
the internal press the p button to flip
that entirely
and now we have our one single stud
frame sitting on top of that concrete
footing
now i'll highlight this section click it
once click
the control button and drag that section
up three meters to duplicate it right
clicking on it similar to what we did
before we can open in current view
settings so now we're looking at the
beginning of our
timber frame construction connecting to
our actual
concrete floor now to save a little bit
of time i'm actually just going to
exit out of that go back into our brick
construction detail
open those settings and duplicate
this mass footing and concrete slab
i'm also going to duplicate this
waterproofing membrane straight away
as well as our earth and our earth line
so i'll go
ctrl c close that right click
open with current view settings and
paste now obviously everything
isn't perfectly aligned but that's okay
we can start simply by
extending our earth hatch across and
extending our natural ground level line
across as well what you'll see straight
away here that's different is that
footing probably won't be that big we
can drag that now back maybe about 150
mil to make it a smaller footing again
the engineer will detail this and
this waterproofing membrane is actually
going to be very different to what we
had in the brick coursing
instead of going under this footing
we're actually going to go all the way
around
so what i'll do is i'll drag that back
click the alt button
and draw a brand new polyline
going all the way around that footing
and coming
just past the natural ground level and
past that slab the natural ground level
still slopes back just like it did
before
but this timber frame wall which i've
actually explained in a completely
different video if you want to go back
and check out my 30 minute timber
construction guide what we do is
basically have a series of
timber battens and along the bottom we
would have our base plate
so if we come across and type in stud
now what would happen in this situation
to the bottom of that timber floor is
we would have a bottom plate actually
sitting on that floor so i'll change all
of these settings here to square
solid line black and we'd go ahead and
draw a 90 by 45
timber frame let's bring that to the
absolute
front so we can see it now finally to
make this detail completed there would
be a bolt or a screw or some sort of
concrete anchor
sitting on top of this bottom plate
going directly
in to the concrete slab now depending on
a number of factors and what the
engineer determines it could be
just your typical concrete screw it
could be chemi anchored
it could be a whole bunch of variety of
things so that will be determined by the
engineer
it will be very site specific so i'm not
going to draw it in i'm just going to
articulate it so you're made aware
however fundamentally speaking that is a
very simple
structural detail for how a timber frame
wall sits on
top of the edge of a concrete slab and
the concrete slab then
sits on a footing itself this strip
footing would wrap around the entire
edge of that slab the slab would be a
hundred mils throughout consistently 85
mil depending on the engineer's detail
and then it would thicken out like i've
shown in this detail here
to the edges to sit on that footing
correctly
now also inside of this concrete slab
what i haven't drawn or what i haven't
shown
is the small little chairs that sit
inside and the rio bars that strengthen
the actual concrete slab again this is
determined by the engineer what size of
rio you need
in that concrete slab again depending on
a whole bunch of different factors
so once again i won't draw it in but be
aware that there is a lot more than just
solid mass concrete poured into a slab
so section two is now completed and
we're going to move on
to our concrete tilt-up wall sitting on
a concrete
slab so what i'll do is once again i'll
simply copy these so i don't have to
redraw them
ctrl c close that and
move across to our next one now simply
move the process along quicker i'll go
control
down arrow select both of these control
d
control holding shift pressing d
moving three meters up so that we have
our slab created and we have our sexual
marker created
as well now fortunately by default in
the wall tools we do not have a tilt-up
concrete wall
pre-defined for us i'm not going to
explain this in that video how to create
a new wall i've explained that in
previous videos
i will just simply dive in to this
section here
and start detailing it more so in 2d to
give you a fundamental understanding so
straight away i'm going to click ctrl
v to paste that concrete slab that we
created before and the footing itself
as well as the waterproofing membrane
i'm going to move the waterproofing
membrane just out of the way for now
and i'm going to extend the size of this
footing down below at the moment it's
300 i'm going to extend that
to 800 wide in total making sure
i extend the earth as well so it can be
seen and instead of 172 drop here i'm
gonna have a
400 millimeter drop now that isn't
obviously going to work straight away
so what i'll do is i'll drag that across
so
it doesn't disappear and push that down
228 before i finish off moving all my
earth hatches what i'm going to do is
i'm going to move
that concrete footing centered 400
millimeters
and then i'm also going to extend that
let's call it 250 so it has an edge
thickening
now i can finish off my earth hatch
adjustment
accordingly okay so now we have the
commencement of our tilt-up concrete
panel
the fundamental principle of tilt-up
concrete is form that concrete panel on
site
and tilt it up hence the name what we're
going to do now is i'm
going to use the alt command to select
this pattern again because it is
structural concrete and i'm going to
draw
a 180 thick by
one meter concrete slab so let's drop
that in there i'm going to extend that a
little bit higher just so we can see it
properly
and i'm then going to chamfer these
corners
so there's a number of ways you can do
that you can click on this
go to the champa fill it go chamfer and
let's call it a 25mm
chamfer and we'll do the same principle
here
so that's just how concrete panel is
made it does have the small chamfers on
the edges
so you can actually draw them in you
don't have to if you don't want to but
it is a nice detail and it makes this
detail a lot more clean a lot more
thought out i'll then move this up about
25 millimeters
so we can insert our packer underneath
so similar to what we did with the
timber construction a minute ago
we're just going to draw a small box
here 130
by 25 and then we're going to draw an
x through the middle of it now that
concrete wall sits on top of a packer
for stability and rigidity those packers
will be about 1200
centers depending on again what the
engineer specifies in this instance
now obviously you can't just bring up a
giant concrete wall and sit it like this
against a concrete footing and pad some
earth next to it and hope for the best
it actually has to be physically
connected
so it doesn't fall over whenever there's
a light breeze
now i'm just going to make a small
little cleat here let's call it 10 mil
by 150
and do the same thing here 150 by 10 mil
we'll connect them and drag that to the
bottom
so first of all you would have that
steel cleat along the bottom
the steel cleat would have a bolt
running right through the bottom
here so for articulation purposes only
there would be a bolt
right there the second bolt connecting
directly in
to this panel wall that would be done on
site once it's lifted
whilst you would also have a metal rod
coming
through the concrete tilt-up panel and
into the concrete slab now that metal
rod depending on the construction
methods depending on the builder
depending on the engineer
could be cast in situ into that actual
slab during the pour
it could be placed during the
construction it could be drilled out now
finally all we're missing
is our waterproofing membrane so we'll
delete that so we can create a new one
because this is very different once
again
it would sit under our slab like it
always does and
just like brick coursing it would sit
underneath and in between
our concrete tilt up wall and our
concrete slab now from a construction
detail point of view
that is the fundamentals of how tilt-up
concrete wall
would connect to the concrete slab
itself and the footing that footing
would be
significantly deeper it would be
something along those lines
it would definitely not be a small
footing because that concrete wall is
very big and very heavy so speaking from
a construction point of view that
section of earth there would actually be
backfilled
after these bolts here had been
installed into the footing and into the
concrete wall
this rod could be a number of different
ways depending on the construction of
itself
but overall speaking that is the tilt-up
wall
that is the slab and that is the detail
completed
so to continue with the brick theme i'm
going to go to the retaining wall
detail now now the retaining wall would
obviously be somewhere on the site
it could be along the edge of the
building but in this case we're just
doing a simple planter retaining wall so
let's go back down to our footings layer
let's copy that up three meters just
like we did before
move another layer up and select our
wall tool coming into our wall tool
and just quickly looking for a cavity
filled retaining wall once again we do
not have that
but i do want to draw a cavity wall in
here as best i can
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
select this 110 mil
brick work with plaster on the outside
so it'd be rendered
so let's start in the middle of this
footing drawing one wall on the outside
simply showing it there and duplicating
and mirroring it on the outside so
control
m lets us mirror and i'm going to move
that 300 millimeters across
sectional detail open and we can just
delete that one because it's not
really helping us here in any way shape
or form we're going to start with a fill
tool we're going to go into our fill
we're going to select our structural
concrete and
change those settings how we had them
before what i'm going to do
is actually draw a 1.5 meter wide
by let's call it 500 deep footing
and then i'm literally just going to
center it to
the center of that wall now unlike that
exterior brick wall that we did
this is slightly different we are
actually going to have
approximately 300 millimeters right down
the center
of concrete filled cavity brickwork
so we'll have our traditional 110
millimeter brick on the outside
110 millimeter brick on the other side
and then once that wall has been built
and erected
then they will pour the concrete
directly inside
of that cavity now altogether that would
work
quite well but it would still be very
unstable so what would happen on site
is if we just change that keeping it
blue for the simple purposes of argument
there would be a starter bar which is a
metal rod
that runs inside the concrete will arch
that
so it is a nice j loop there would be a
concrete
bar cast into the footing originally
when it was being poured
and it would stick up through the ground
ready for the brickwork and the cavity
concrete to be filled into it
secondary on top of that there would
most likely be another
rio bar running all the way through
potentially
in different directions again depending
on the engineer's detail
to be able to strengthen and support
that 300 millimeters of
concrete now to finish off that detail
we'll go back to this
and we'll simply just draw some earth
across
both sides and we'll select an earth
hatch here as well
now depending on the actual structure
and where this retaining wall is
actually retaining earth
it would more likely be something along
these lines here
because we want to actually be retaining
earth is well the whole purpose of a
retaining wall
so that you can have two different
ground levels on either side
this footing here could be on this side
it could be on
this side it could be on the other side
it could be
wherever it's required to be depending
on a number of factors again where the
boundary is
where it's retaining the earth how the
engineer details it what the soil is and
a whole bunch of different factors
however the retaining wall detail
is typically used in this situation to
be able to depict the two different
ground levels
it is a very simple detail it isn't
something that is overly complex
but hopefully that gives you a good
understanding of how the retaining wall
works moving on to our fifth and final
detail let's close out of that one
we'll go ctrl c let's simply just copy
this section across another three meters
and move back up to our floor plan what
i'll do is select my column tool
let's go to a steel column we'll open up
all the settings so we can go through
it it'll be an 89 by 89 millimeter steel
column that's a traditional
column here in australia again all sorts
of different
metal steel across the world we'll put a
wall thickness in there just for fun
let's call it four millimeters it's
very thick all we'll do now is click ok
and drop that column directly in the
middle of our section
now still columns are very simple detail
once again and they're most likely going
to be detailed by a structural engineer
unless there's an architectural feature
around there that is critical just like
all of the rest of these details
they will be predominantly provided by
the structural engineer
it's our job then to go and enhance them
from an architectural point of view
but without knowing the fundamental
basics of how this works
you won't be able to do anything
architecturally speaking
so opening up this sectional view with
open current view settings
we can see our column coming straight
through and let's go ahead
and draw a nice footing here like we did
for the retaining wall itself so let's
draw a 600 by 300 footing
let's drag that to the center of our
column right here
and then what i'm going to do let's drop
that 25
mil for the instance now basically what
would happen
with this steel column to the footing
connection
is we would have a base plate that would
look something along
the lines of this i'll draw it very
mediocre
just so we can get an understanding of
what that base plate would look like
and then we would have a little bit of
grout
filled in underneath this section of
that base plate
so the grout would be on top of that
concrete footing
then there would be a base plate for
that steel column and then you'd have
the steel column up above
what would then happen is there would be
two bolts bolted on site as that steel
column is put into place
those anchors there unlike the timber
would most likely be a chemi anchored
bolt
because it is a structural element that
we're talking about
so the chemi anchored bolt is something
again depicted by the structural
engineer
not necessarily defined by the architect
but something that we need to be aware
of
is basically a pre-drilled hole a bolt
goes into that hole and then it is
filled
with some sort of chemical resin that
expands fills that hole up and makes
sure it is a very snug
fit from a sectional architectural point
of view this
detail is horrendously ugly and
industrial
this might be a flat bar plate so
instead of looking
a little bit curved it could be a flat
bar plate
like i've just shown there so it is
easier to fix that bolt too
again depending on what we detail what
we specify
but you'd still have the bolt heads
sitting above
something like that so unless you
actually look at the engineering details
and look how it needs to be connected in
that particular area
you're not going to know what to do from
an architectural point of view
now we could box that out we could
plaster it we could hide it inside a
concrete wall
we could hide it inside a brick wall you
could do a number of things
to make that column disappear but you
just have to be aware of that detail
here
so that's why i've selected the column
sectional detail
because it is more of an architectural
detail that needs to be considered
than anything else personally speaking
what a nice architectural detail would
be
would be a simple recess into the
concrete footing so let's recess that
we'll call that 25 millimeters and
select all of our column at our base
plate allowing
that to be recessed into the concrete so
it's a nice
flush detail and all you have to worry
about then is
the bolts we can get flathead bolts we
can then drag that down something like
this
have very small flathead bolts so it
isn't seen
and then potentially if you have some
sort of sheeting covering over the top
be it tiles be it carpet you might be
able to hide that
if the bolts are good enough and you
actually detail it properly
but without drawing this sectional
detail you'll most likely have a very
ugly connection
from an architectural point of view
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video
i hope you learned some critical and
valuable information out of it
if you did make sure you check out the
links down below there is a discord chat
where you can actually download this
archicad file for yourself you have to
sign up as a patreon
legend level member but that means every
week i do a tutorial
you get that arc cad file to download
save and
understand further use it however you
wish if you enjoyed the video make sure
you smash that subscribe button and
don't forget about the like button the
like button somehow or another believe
it or not
helps with the youtube algorithm helps
me continue creating these videos and
helps other people learn
valuable information like i said that's
all from me today
so i will see you next monday